(upbeat techno music)
- [Keith] Anything that you do
definitely has the element of power.
When you're actually out there,
and you're actually voguing
or you’re actually walking,
and the beat is taking you,
then you just go for it.
(upbeat music)
- My name is Keith Holt.
When I'm out at the balls,
I become Keith Ebony
the crown prince of Baltimore.
Voguing, it's an underground art form,
that was brought to like throw
shade on the dance floor.
Ballroom in general was
developed to be underground.
Partially because of so
much stigma and hate
that the LGBT community have experienced.
This is a place that you can
be anything that you want to be
James is like that new
generation of voguers.
- How you doin? I'm the
Legendary Lil James Khan.
I'm the vogue fem extraordinaire.
- [Keith] He is like the
Beyoncé of the ballroom scene.
Mook is my best friend.
- I am the voice of
Baltimore, Mook Mizrahi.
The dramatic one.
- [Keith] He commentates, he vogue.
James, Mook, and myself
are some people that
are really leading the next generation.
(upbeat music)
- [Keith] I work for the
Baltimore city health department.
I'm the youth outreach coordinator.
With that I kind of come up
with the different events.
And something that kept coming up was,
why not throw a ball?
So we have our free ball.
And because Baltimore
has a high rate in HIV,
that's why we make sure that
every event that we have
we do offer both HIV
testing and HIV linkage
to treatment as well.
For me it's really like
this is not just a job.
This is my community.
These are people that I know.
Ballroom is not just a
extracurricular activity anymore.
It's actually now a part of my life.
(upbeat music)